hallo liebe leute will heute mit dana in
münchen endlich mal wieder da wenn ich
freue mich so sehr und wir machen heute
einen doppel video ja wir haben ein
video gerade aufgenommen für das kernel
mit fun fact trug falls über die usa und
das gleich man jetzt über deutschland
ihr dürft mit raten die menschen auf der
straße dürfen mit raten und dana ist
quasi die die stellvertretend als erste
raten darf für alle
wir fangen mal an erste frage an dana
und dann an die menschen auf der straße
dann aber schon mit der ersten frage ja
die sind alle durcheinander meine fragen
aber ich glaube diese ist am
spannendsten und zwar wahr oder falsch
deutschland ist das land mit dem
höchsten bierkonsum der welt ich würde
sagen tschechien verdammt jetzt gucken
wir mal was die leute auf der straße
sagen wahr oder falsch waren stärker ich
weiß nicht ich würde sagen nicht
unbedingt was würden sie denken die
irgendwie ich würde jetzt irland
ich bin mir nicht sicher ich glaube die
tschechen sind noch davor hat er hier
ist deutschland auf platz zwei iphones
sind die tschechin dana hat die frage
natürlich richtig beantwortet weil du
hast in tschechien gelegen ein jahr im
vergessen natürlich weißt du das aber es
ist ein häufiges missverständnis wie die
leute denken keiner hat trinkt mehr bier
als die deutschen es gibt tatsächlich
eine nation und nur eine auf der welt
die mehr bier trinkt als die deutschen
das sind die tschechen gar nicht
schlechter hagen gut zu wässern
bist du bereit für folgezeit ich bin
bereit der fakt fakt 2 ist in
deutschland gibt es keine todesstrafe
drohe falls ich würde sagen wie in
wahr oder falsch
wahrscheinlich ist er in irgendeinem
uralt gesetz noch verankert und wurde
aufgehoben
also nicht aufgehoben aber wird halt
nicht mal verzogen oder du weißt nicht
alles in welchem bundesland ist sie
formal noch existent es muss ein altes
bundesland sein weil die neueren haben
sicherlich nicht aber wahrscheinlich ist
es tatsächlich bayern alleine feiern
soll
glück gehabt ist es nicht bayern wird
sagen berlin
naja dann weiß ich nicht hessen hessen
klar
und hier ist die auflösung dana es gibt
in deutschland die todesstrafe will
nicht das würde rein ist offensichtlich
ja aber sie wird nicht mehr ausgeführt
oder im gesetz tatsächlich von den
einzelnen ländern von unseren
bundesländern gibt es vereinzelt noch
die todesstrafe zum beispiel in hessen
steht diese heute noch im gesetz aber
sie wird nicht mehr ausgeführt
aber es ist witzig die deutschland ag
scheiß amerikaner um die todesstrafe
aber in wirklichkeit haben wir die auch
noch im gesetz stehen wahr oder falsch
das oktoberfest findet im oktober statt
nur ein bisschen fast alles ist eben
september erinnern und das denkt man
natürlich nicht dass halo das denkt man
natürlich nicht er kam gerade hier die
polizei auf pferden vorbei so ist das im
münchner wäre ich nicht auch ganz lecker
das oktoberfest wird tatsächlich im
september statt größtenteils wenn man
feiert quasi den anfang des oktober und
man feiert vor dem oktober schon ein
paar tage tatsächlich im oktober
wusstet ihr dass ich leb glaube ich
schon lange noch hier und ich würde
sagen ja dass es wichtig war drei tage
nimmt es mit also seit ende september
nimmt den letzten 3 oktober der ersten
drei tage mit dann bist du bereit für
frage vier super bereit die vierte frage
ist oder die vierte aussage ist bier
trinken ist überall in deutschland
erlaubt wahr oder falsch
oh oh ich will sagen also sage ich ich
glaube auch ja doch in jedem platz
im u bahn nein in den verkehrsmitteln
ist es verboten darf nicht überall
erlaubt
überall in bayern ja ich glaube nicht
überall ich mich hier in münchen ich bin
mir nicht sicher ich glaube in der s
bahn darf man nicht dringend ja du hast
recht
tatsächlich ist wir trinken überall in
deutschland erlaubt dir eigentlich das
ist ja das tolle in deutschland wir
deutschen lieben das wahnsinnig gerne
wenn wir im ausland sind aus amerika
wieder kommen sagt er sei am flughafen
bier aufgemacht weil wir uns der frei
deutschen freiheit erfreuen
aber natürlich ist es nicht überall
erlaubt man darf zum beispiel manchmal
man darf in bestimmten gebäuden nicht
trinken darf in der bahn nicht trinken
aber aber auch auf einzelnen plätzen
kann es lokal verboten werden zum
beispiel vor einer kirche wollen will
die kirche nicht dass da jeden abend bis
auf eine jugendliche abhängt also kann
man das lokal es an manchen orten
verbieten ja und in münchen so leute
sollen leute nicht im u bahn trinken
aber sehr oft leute damit eine in berlin
davon offiziell auch keinen alkohol
trinkt in der u-bahn trinken aber
natürlich machen das alle und es wird
auch nicht kontrollieren ok dann afr
nummer 55 der mittelfinger ist in
deutschland verboten
diese oder falsch
verboten war ganz verboten
der mittelfinger ist verboten in
deutschland als verboten sollte man
nicht machen machen sie aber trotzdem
gut findest du das überraschende wie
gibt es hohe strafen darauf darf man
nicht machen ja ich weiß es nicht genau
was ist auf jeden fall so beim
autofahren sollte man sich da hüten
es ist tatsächlich verboten ja ich also
ich meine nein ich mache das hier sinn
aber es ist tatsächlich auch eine eine
straftat sozusagen ist eine beleidigung
und wenn du jetzt zum beispiel zu mir
das machst dann kann ich zur polizei
gehen und dich anzeigen wirklich ob sie
das verfolgen ist eine andere frage weil
manchmal ist es ja auch nicht so einfach
das zu beweisen
münchen ist die zweitgrößte stadt
deutschlands wahr oder falsch nackten in
fahrt also ich komme ursprünglich aus
kroatien ich hatte sagen falsch weil
berlin ist größer und ich glaube hamburg
ist auch und ticken größe allein schon
den genauso fläche richtig ich würde
sagen geht größte richtig danach richten
welche sind größer berlin haben wir gute
flanken aber ich weiß nicht welche
hamburg liebe leute das war unser video
heute wir haben es hat euch gefallen es
war mal ein bisschen anders als sonst
heute ging es um fakten und fragen über
deutschland wir hoffen ihr habt auch was
mitgenommen und was gelernt danke dana
dass dabei war ja das war super das
hatten uns hergefallen und jetzt ist
natürlich die frage für euch möchtet ihr
auch mal sehen wie ich fragen beantworte
zu den usa ich habe mich ja ich war
nicht so gut da in den antworten höhe
sein
sie ist 50 50 15 gefahr guckt mal rein
hier einmal hier seht ihr das
mir würde das video auf das channel wo
wir das ganze umgekehrt gemacht haben
nämlich fragen über die usa und wenn ihr
lust habt uns zu unterstützen und auch
texte dieser episode zu sehen und vor
allem auch material- und übungen zu
bekommen zur episode sand schaut mal
hier unten vorbei und natürlich
abonniert easy german bis nächste woche
auf wiedersehen